des dizaines de personnes font la file
pour obtenir une dédicace du dernier
livre
dany laferrière c'est l'une des
nombreuses activités organisées pour la
journée des librairies indépendantes des
endroits essentiels pour la diversité
littéraire
selon l'académicien québécois de
permettre à ce que des livres qui ne
s'adresse pas à tout le monde c'est à
dire qui et demande une participation
plus active aux lecteurs de rester quand
même sur les tablettes et de n'est pas
uniquement proposer des livres qui ont
la faveur et du moment à la librairie de
verdun où il se trouve
les affaires vont bien l'endroit à
tripler sa superficie depuis son
ouverture il ya une dizaine d'années les
clients sont au rendez vous
les gens s'approprient les librairies
indépendantes vient nous voir viennent
consulter pour des conseils mais aussi
pour découvrir de nouvelles chine de
nouvelles lectures de nouveaux auteurs
c'est un peu beaucoup notre but est
effectivement ça va vraiment très très
bien on voit des augmentations année
après année les librairies indépendantes
peuvent tourner la page sur les années
difficiles marquées par de nombreuses
fermetures
alors que les ventes de livres sont en
baisse dans les grandes chaînes de
librairies au québec
elles sont plutôt en hausse chez les
indépendants depuis quelques années l'an
dernier elles ont atteint 231 millions $
un bond de 7 pour ça tout le débat
public autour d'eux notamment l'équité
fiscale de certains géants du web a un
impact je pense en effet boomerang sur
l'achat local puis l'achat responsable
chez le public ce consommateur pour
tirer leur épingle du jeu
les indépendants mise sur une grande
sélection d'oeuvres et au service à la
clientèle personnalisé
une formule qui semble appréciée par les
clients de la librairie le port de tête
sur le plateau mont royal
on peut trouver des choses qu'on peut
pas trouver arnaud breuillac souterrain
ici on vraiment une super sélection et
autant de littérature québécoise en
littérature jeunesse le ce
extraordinaire c'est toujours un peu
plus personnelles comme filet tout le
monde ici sans l'affection de la
clientèle pour notre librairie
indépendante
et puis forcément ça se traduit à la
caisse
c'est un nouveau chapitre qui s'ouvre
pour les libraires indépendants ici
olivier bastin radio canada montréal